[Music]
with me here today is Adrienne Graham a
cloud solutions architect for media and
entertainment my name is Ari Lieberman
I'm a product manager for Google compute
engine and for cloud GPUs so let's get
right into it
thanks Aaron so we have a few things to
talk about today this is an introductory
session so I want to talk about how far
we've come in the past year since we
introduced the first generation cloud
GPU we're going to be talking about some
exciting announcements we have for you
around virtual work stations on GCP and
then I'm gonna hand that over to
Adrienne who's going to be speaking
about building a visual effects studio
in the cloud and show you with a demo so
last year around the February of 2017 we
introduced our first generation cloud
GPU the k80
it's an nvidia tesla GPU which come a
long way since then but i'm just gonna
give you a quick refresher on why cloud
GPUs computation and graphics intensive
applications have have need for
massively parallel computation this
means that a lot of the processing that
you could do in a CPU it's not enough to
do some jobs like high performance
computing and machine learning when you
compare and contrast a GPU to a CPU you
CPUs are great for many for many jobs
for just like your typical operations
for they come from perform a lot of jobs
but the GPU can do a lot more parallel
processing for example a CPU can have in
the order of 20 to 40 cores per CPU and
if you have multiple sockets you can
scale up to up to 160 course like we
have in their recently announced the
ultramen machine but on a GPU can have
in the order of 5000 or or even more
extreme processors so you can perform a
lot of parallel computation very quickly
[Applause]
the other advantage of GPUs is that it
has much higher memory bandwidth so you
can be moving data across very quickly
compared to a CPU where that might be
slow
and that's why in the past few years
which in a significant uptake for many
applications and especially using today
a lot of announcements on machine
learning where there's been a crazy
demand for four accelerators in the
cloud for things like machine learning
in training and machine learning
inference and then we have also known
that GPUs are very popular for
applications like simulation genomics
and of course visualization so one of
our objectives on Google cloud platform
is to give you one place where you can
accelerate all of your workloads
regardless of what that is so you might
have a need for for Intel skylake CPUs
we introduced skylight before any other
cloud provider back last year we have a
broad range of NVIDIA GPUs and you saw
today's some more information on cloud
CPUs which are accelerators for machine
learning training optimized for tensor
flow so one of the new additions today
to this family is that we have a
graphics optimized offering and I'll be
talking more about that in a second so
why Google cloud and I think you've seen
this over the years so we have one of
the best infrastructures we've built
fiber optics thousands of miles under
the ocean and over land and you have
very scalable performance and reliable
reliable performance we've also been
working for many years in optimizing our
VMs
and our boot times so you can create up
to 4,000 instances in less than a minute
that's something you cannot do anywhere
else this is all with our security built
in so we've learned from building
services like Gmail you saw today from
our card talking about Gmail and how far
we've come there so from building
services that have over a billion users
we take some of those lessons and we
apply them to GCE and also you get the
benefits of per second billing so it's
not you only pay for the resources for
the exact time that you use them not for
ours or any or any longer
so how did you how does a cloud GPU work
then what works is when you create an
instance if you're familiar with our
custom machine types you can create a
machine with as many courses you need
however much memory you need and then
you can attach anywhere from 1 up to 8
GPUs so you have a lot of flexibility
and this is something that you cannot
find anywhere else this means that if
your application is very memory bound
you can add more more memory if you need
a lot more GPUs to do things like
machine learning you can attach them and
you can get your job done much faster
and what if you know if you don't need
any of them you can optimize and save a
lot of money and that's for example if
you're doing a simulation that requires
very few course some memory you were
scaling up to a thousand notes imagine
if you multiply that times the amount of
memory for HDM you end up saving a lot
of money in the long run so we give you
that flexibility so you only pay what
you for what you use and it's by the
second some of the other cloud GPU
features is that you get the GPU in
faster mode this means that you get the
bare metal performance we don't
visualize the device I talked about
custom machines and that's a significant
benefit I talked about first second
billing but I think most importantly you
get a broad range of frameworks for
example with NVIDIA GPUs you have CUDA
you have CU DNN we have tested
tensorflow and other frameworks so if
there's a very broad ecosystem and you
can take advantage of that or regardless
with your application if it's simulation
or machine running or visualization so
today we have three families of GPUs the
kad the P 100 that we introduced in
September of last year and the V 100
there's different combinations depending
on the accelerator for example with the
e 100 you can attach up to four GPUs
with Volta or latest-generation which
was introduced a few months ago
you can attach up to eight one of the
benefits of the latest generation the
Volta GPU is that gas and video link and
B link which is a high speed
connectivity across GPUs so your
application can take advantage of a
bigger a bigger memory and much faster
computation
you can also these are some of the
ranges also sphere you can see on how
many GPUs and how many cores and you
have a lot of flexibility and how you
can customize your instance so I'm going
to talk about a little bit about
workstations now and I have some
announcements for you today so first if
you're in the in some industries like
you have a graphics workstation like
media and entertainment or oil and gas
you typically go but by a quadrille card
you deploy under your desk or in some
data center and I think that there's a
lot of advances in the recent years that
sometimes make that stale so you have a
GPU that might be a few years old it's
not easy to keep up with all the driver
updates and to keep all the software
updates and also some of the application
providers don't give consistent support
across all the different devices it's
getting better and we working from our
partners at it that there's more
consistency but it's still a challenge
one of the other problems is that you
might have silos you're working in let's
say in LA and you're trying to connect
somebody in montréal or London and
moving data it's very slow it's
difficult and and it's also you don't
know if there's enough security so you
need to make sure that all of your data
is safe at all times and one of the
other challenges is that if for example
you're rendering a large movie you want
to make sure that you have access to
other services so when you when you
press the button to start doing the
rendering that's Oliver in close
proximity and and you can do this much
faster so today we're gonna change this
and we're introducing a new type of
accelerator and Google compute engine
we're into this in the Nvidia test lab
before that before is a graphics
optimized GPU from Nvidia but it's not
only a graphics GPU the I'm gonna talk
about some of the specs on the p4 and
why it's different with a p4 you get
eight gigabytes of frame buffer so you
have a a gigabytes of memory for your
graphics intensive application he has
close to 200 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth but it's not only good
for graphics it's a card that is great
for compute so if you're doing things
like machine learning inference to give
you an example or if you're doing video
transcoding
it's a great fit for those use cases
- it also has decoding and encoding
agents so it's great for video
transcoding with t4 with before we're
also introducing Nvidia great support
this means that you get the a Quadra
virtual workstation in the cloud with
multiple monitor support 4k resolution
with the latest generation workstation
class GPU this includes support for
pascal features and deep learning and
all and this is up to 1.3 x the
performance of previous generation tesla
GPUs what this means in the end is that
you can take on the biggest challenges
things like photo realistic environments
immersive applications and as i
mentioned before you get the GPU and
fast through mode so you get the most
performance out of your GPU the way you
attach a virtual workstation to any
instance is the same as you do with a
with a GPU you take you select the
accelerator type in this case the nvidia
tesla p4 and it's very simple you just
append - vws that converts the tesla p4
GPU which is a compute card into a
virtual workstation you can select
anywhere from 1 to 4 and in this case
i'm creating a custom machine type with
64 cores and 300 gigabytes of memory but
we didn't stop there
we're also at introducing support for P
100 so you can turn a p1 if you need
more memory or more power for your
application let's say you're doing
simulation with something like discovery
live you need to be able to take
advantage of more of the simulation
capabilities of your GPU so you can turn
that P 100 with great support into a
virtual workstation if you need that
much power one of our customers number
Jay has been using cloud GPUs since last
year and sunberg a they they have very
demanding needs for simulation but also
for visualization they've deployed
virtual workstations in several regions
and they're oil and gas
subject matter experts can power their
Petro technical suite in the Delphi
cognitive and EMT environment and they
can power devices all over the globe
they take advantage of our low latency
Network and also our global availability
of GPUs to make to allow their users to
make more informed decisions from oil
and gas exploration all the way to
production so it's been very very good
for them since we introduced this in
alpha a few months ago here's a pricing
on P for the
before GPU starts at 60 cents an hour
you can you can / GP you you can attach
one two or four GPUs and it's the same
memory and four configurations as a P
100 GPU but there's one addition which
you need a great license so there's 20
cents an hour per gate license per hour
if you need more power as I mentioned
earlier you can also use a few 100 GPU
and the p180 you starts on one dollar
and 40 cents an hour 46 cents an hour
and you can also add the great license
to that to come up with a total cost
before GPUs and p1r GPUs also are
supported in preemptable so they're
allowed for less than 24 hours and they
can be preempted at any time so this is
also supported with a fee for Mt 100 one
of our partners and customers give up
technology they've been using a variety
for NVIDIA GPUs with for virtual
workstations and they've had great
success with media and entertainment
customers and before is gonna be rolling
out over the next few weeks we're gonna
have them available in locations like
Iowa in Northern Virginia and
Netherlands and I think for a media
entertainment customers they're gonna be
available in LA as well as Montrell over
the coming weeks we have more regions
launching sometime in q4 in the end of
this year so stay tuned you're gonna be
rolling out throughout this year in more
locations but your your application and
your GPU it's not only about the
hardware that you have you also need a
great client to be able to experience
the best graphics application so we
partnered with Terra DT to provide cloud
access plus software through the Google
cloud marketplace so you can go in
create an instance and then use the
fairly cheap PC over IP protocol this
means that you get color accurate and
and lossless video quality so I think
this is a great addition that will make
a lot of our customers very successful
the CEO of 30 team that's share that
they've been testing on p4 and P 100 and
enabling some of their customers and
they basically they seen a lot of
success and a lot of great feedback so
far so with that I'm gonna hand it over
to Adrian who's gonna be talking about
how to build a virtual affects duty in
the cloud and thank you all right Thank
You Ari so a little introduction
I'm a cloud solutions architect for
media and entertainment working in Los
Angeles and I spent but prior to Google
working at Google I spent 20 years
working in visual effects worked at some
big facilities worked on big films and I
mostly worked on the tech side in the
pipeline side so basically it was my job
to make things work for all the artists
so my job now at Google is to figure out
how to run all those same workloads but
on the cloud so we've been doing a lot
of really interesting stuff and I'm
going to sort of go into a little more
tech detail some of the stuff that
already mentioned first let's have a
little a little primer as to what an
architecture might look like to deploy a
virtual workstation so we're gonna start
on the left on the screen left hand side
you've got your your laptops or what's
called a zero client which is a thin
client and you've got a gateway an
Internet gateway and you need to call it
can to connect to the cloud well you can
connect over public internet that's fine
depending on the protocol you use to
connect it's encrypted or not encrypted
hopefully encrypted there's also a
connectivity cloud interconnect products
that we offer like cloud VPN or
dedicated interconnect which is a ten
gigabit line you can have up to eight of
them right into a Google Data Center and
that reduces latency and ping times the
number of hops etc etc it's based on
where you are located in the world but
what we're doing is we're connecting
directly to a virtual workstation this
is the simplest case right where we just
have an IP address of a virtual machine
and you just plug right into it
and I'm going to show you that in a
second however if you have more than one
virtual workstation
you can't just click a button and deploy
deploy deploy what if you have a hundred
artists all working you're going to need
a connection broker or a management
layer or an orchestration layer and
that's what Ari was talking about
bebop technologies offers and there's
other partners that offer that as well
on Google cloud platform so then we
start to build out our infrastructure
and this is the license server that the
NVIDIA Grid license that Ari was talking
about it is completely transparent to
the user by the way once you configure a
virtual workstation with a certain type
of accelerator it automatically talks to
the grid license server draws a license
so you don't have to worry about hooking
up to it this license server however is
what I'm using
it's just a small VM a cloud license or
I'm using to provide licenses for my
third-party software I'm using Maya and
Houdini for example I'll show you that
in a second and then there's some other
some other data storage platforms that
you might need some shared file system
or if you want to use cloud storage
those are all connected to your virtual
workstation which is a virtual machine
running on GCP just like any virtual
workstation or sorry any virtual machine
that you have and then we can expand out
and this is getting a little bit more
into the visual effects era and that's
you know we've got render workers which
perform offline compute for our that
feed data back to our virtual work
stations and then we can orchestrate it
all by with a queue manager to
distribute tasks and everything so this
might seem slightly familiar to you if
you're not in visual effects or
animation or in the entertainment
industry but really they're all the same
components you have a bunch of compute
that you need to send out to different
workers and orchestrate it get it back
recorded in database database entries
but the big difference here is that
we're able to visualize it so I'm gonna
take you through a quick pretend day in
the life of an artist and there's a few
people in the audience that know what
this is all about let's pretend that at
10 a.m. and artist rolls in and they're
reviewing their shots or their feedback
from the night before
so they only need a modest workstation
they don't need
massive workstation so they can spin up
a machine with only eight CPUs and 8
gigs of ram and a p4 for example that's
a relatively inexpensive workstation and
it's a it's it's a decent power but once
they get feedback and they need to start
really doing some work like doing some
fluid simulations or some you know crazy
amounts of compute they could
reconfigure their virtual workstation
add more CPUs add more RAM and add more
GPUs multiple GPUs and this is one of
the key elements of GCP is that you can
attach GPUs to almost any configuration
of machine you dial up or down how many
how much ram how many CPUs and you can
also add multiple GPUs depending on the
type of GPU you can add 1 2 or 4 P fours
or p1 hundreds for example or if you're
using v1 hundreds you can have up to
eight B 100's which is mind-blowing ly
powerful okay so this artist is is done
with that task but now they need to
render it so they need even more power
but they don't need massive amounts of
CPUs they need massive amounts of GPUs
so say for example they're doing they're
doing GPU rendering well they could
attach a bunch of GPS to their local
workstation or they can deploy a cluster
of machines with GPUs attached and
address those in a certain way I'm
actually going to show you how to do
that and this is this is the game
changer here is that now you you've got
your own personal GPU farm like your own
cluster that you could size up or down
as much or is it use as much or as
little resources as you need and because
these machines are all in the same
region and zone they can talk to each
other really fast I'll get into some of
that in a bit
alright so let's pretend that the artist
is done at 6:00 p.m. which never happens
all right they stop their machine and
they don't pay for it Oh too fast there
they don't pay for it so these are all
rough calculations of what it would cost
to run any one of these configurations
on a per hour basis build by the second
but at night when they go home they're
not using it so they're not paying for
it and also you're not paying for a you
know a substantially powerful system
what you're only doing like email
and you know viewing viewing movie files
and getting feedback from the director
the night before so that's I think
that's the power of cloud that's really
unique in that you can deploy these
resources as you need them and size them
exactly as you need them so now let's
move on the others an individual that
was an individual workstation set up but
now let's consider what it takes to
deploy an entire studio or and when I
say studio it doesn't have to be a
creative content studio this could be
just any group of users that wants to
access a bunch of virtual workstations
alright so the three major things we
need to talk about latency bandwidth
egress latency is simply how long it
takes signal to go from your entry point
whether it's a laptop like I'm using now
or a zero client to the GPU or to the
machine and back and you know round-trip
time for the example I give here is how
long it takes to go to our Oregon data
center and it's about it's about 31
milliseconds roundtrip and of course it
depends on your connectivity that's
actually from from the wired connection
of my laptop here if you do it over
Wi-Fi it's gonna be slower if you do it
with a dedicated interconnect and you're
in San Francisco it's gonna be faster
and that's Ari was mentioning we've
deployed GPUs we're gonna be deploying
GPUs and some of our metro data centers
so Los Angeles is coming online soon
Montreal London those are all and Sydney
those are all centers for media centers
and when you are two milliseconds away
from a data center you've got really
unique capabilities that allow you to
work as if the machine was under your
desk
alright bandwidth is a really
interesting problem and it all depends
on what's on your screen so if you have
a protocol like tera deechi tera DG only
sends the Delta the changing pixels
every refresh every 60 Hertz so that
means that if most of your monitor is
static this is just a animated gif of me
screen capturing moving around in a Maya
scene the stuff that's not changing that
doesn't get resent so the only the stuff
inside that viewport is getting resent
so in an instant
like this you know five megabits
connection is fine but if you're viewing
maybe a full screen video then your
bandwidth requirements are gonna go up
so maybe 15 megabits 20 megabits per
second but what if you put something
like noise on your screen where every
single pixel is changing with every
refresh I mean you could cap it at 50
but it's going to use more and you know
what's hilarious is that the resolution
to your monitor makes a difference how
many monitors makes a difference what
kind of a user you are if you're just
you know if you're like a twitchy artist
and you're constantly moving windows
around and tumbling around the scene and
everything you're gonna use more you can
use more bandwidth and there are ways of
capping this per user so you know you
don't have to worry that they're gonna
saturate like a 10 gig line like one
users going to saturate it so there are
controls and ways to to restrict how
much each user is assigned but the way
that we figure it is that if you have an
artist with dual 2k monitors and they
earn an average workflow you can assign
each artist 40 45 megabits per second
and they'll be fine so that means that
you could fit 50 artists on a single 10
gig line which is not you know that's
not out of the out of reach of most of
most facilities the last piece of the
puzzle is egress so this is something
that everybody that deals with cloud
knows the data that you pull out of
cloud is going to cost you money
egress is a lot lower with a virtual
workstation that you may think it's it's
kind of hard to quantify exactly what a
pixel costs you because a pixel is not
necessarily changing its it's not either
on or off it the the the bit depth that
it is and how its how its deployed and
the protocol that you send it along
makes a difference so I keep talking
about Tara DT only sending the Delta
well that means that you're gonna pay
less for data that's sent down that's
not moving as much if an artist keeps a
video looping on their screen overnight
you're gonna pay for that so you need to
have these controls in place to make
sure that idle resources resources that
aren't being attended to are not you
know utilizing excess bandwidth
this is an actual chart of I think three
months of my egress usage and I've been
demoing this stuff all the time
and it comes to a total of three dollars
and 79 cents it's a lot lower than you
might think but there are computations
and calculations that you can use to do
rough estimates so one other one final
thing before we get into the demo and
that's you really need a dedicated line
if you really want to have a cloud
studio you need to have an isolated line
that is designed designated just for
transmission to and from your virtual
workstations we've had some people run
proof of concepts and they say they
complain to us that oh it started
getting really slow I don't know what's
going on and you know might we have a 50
you know gig or a hundred gig connection
well it turns out that they had some
massive espera upload going that was
totally stepping on and crushing their
bandwidth so this just goes to show you
need to have dedicated bandwidth and an
assigned allotment per user on there all
right so the demo that I'm going to show
you basically takes you down the path of
three steps or the sort of a three step
journey the first journey is talking
about only what's only possible on cloud
in general and the second step is only
what's possible on Google Cloud and the
third it's only what's possible on
Google Google Cloud with virtual
workstations so I am on a laptop here
and I I just switched to the Terra DG
client which is a software client runs
on your laptop runs on Windows Mac and
there's also a hardware client which is
a little box but what you're seeing here
this is not there we are so this isn't
very interesting right this is a hundred
and sixty core 160 V CPU machine running
in Oregon that is running six concurrent
fluid simulations using a program called
Houdini I'll get into that in a second
but what this is doing is this is
generating literally terabytes of data
every every hour and it's all it's
writing all that data to a cloud file
store 64 terabyte premium instant cloud
file store I don't
I think it was announced at the at the
the the the keynote but it's it's our
managed shared NFS file system now so up
to 64 terabytes and it is mountable as
an NFS filer on Windows and Linux but
the amazing part here is that so this
data is being written from this one
massive machine so what can I do with
all this data well I can visualize it on
a virtual workstation so first I'm going
to show you this data is when you do a
screen capture of it it looks something
like this I'm running six of these right
now on that virtual workstation this is
pre work this is pre render this is not
running live that you see but I wanted
to give you an idea of why this is
useful these are what we call wedges
when you do a simulation for it doesn't
have to be simulation it could also be
an animation or any type of seem to be
getting a little bit of there we are
it's really hard to tweak all the
parameters at once so what they do is
they'll come up with something that
looks okay and it looks okay and then
they'll deploy six or you know it's ten
or twenty variations that have one tiny
little parameter shifted and then you
can render out each one and you could
view it you could say okay well wedge
one has the parameter set at 0.5 in
which two as the parameter set at 0.75
or something like that and you'll be
able to see oh my god you know just
changing that one little parameter gives
me this massive difference this is the
playback in a movie file it's not
affected this that's why it's a little
choppy but but the idea here is that
I've got that massive machine that's
able to write out all of these
simulations run them all at the same
time and and and and we're able to let
me just quit out of here and we're able
to now visualize them so this is a
program called Houdini let me just get a
little room for my mouse here this data
I'm able to read live off of that file
store this is a different virtual work
state a sorry different machine this is
my virtual workstation I've been viewing
all that on my virtual
station that you've been looking at so
I'm able to read all that data live and
we're talking hundreds of millions of
particles gigabytes of data that is I'm
able to see my mouse keep sliding down
I'm just gonna put this guy down there
I'm able to visualize this stuff and
read it right off that cloud file store
as it's being written by those by that
massive simulation engine alright so
this is really important because now I'm
generating all the data on the cloud and
I'm leaving it up there on the cloud so
I don't have to download these terabytes
of data to my local workstation my
on-prem workstation to do this and I can
access this from anywhere this is I'm on
a laptop here I can take my laptop and
bring it on an airplane and with Wi-Fi
in an airplane I've actually connected
to these workstations before it's not
very you know you got one megabit per
second it's o ter D cheese very adaptive
to different bit rates alright so we've
got this simulation that we've chosen
and and and we like it so now what could
we do with it next I'm going to move
over to an application called Maya now
and again this is all running on the
same machine this is a standard Linux
works to workstation running in Oregon
running sent to a seven-week and ulu in
Windows and Linux so this is an
application called Maya and this is a
this is a meshed version of that
simulation actually let me show you what
that looks like this turn on there we
are so once a simulation is done with
the particle based simulation you can
put it through a process by which you
actually surface it you mesh it and this
is the resulting mesh but this mesh is
in a file format called Alembic and
these files are massive this is I think
a six gigabyte file and I can scrub
through it this is again all stored on
the cloud file store that I was talking
about earlier so I'm able to scrub
around and now I can actually go and
turn on rendering so once we have the
scene simulated and meshed now we want
to look at how to make it appear as if
it's water and a character coming out of
water and
there's a lot more that I can talk about
but I'm running at a time but interview
want to see more we're doing this at a
cloud studio up street and upstairs I'll
talk about that in a second so I'm going
to go into we're using a renderer called
v-ray and v-ray is a company called
chaos group and v-ray takes advantage of
GPUs it has the ability to render on
CPUs or GPUs but because GPUs can run
parallel processes they have a way way
higher core count they can render a lot
faster than on CPUs so here I've got on
this workstation it's a single P 100 and
I'm able to tumble around and look at
this scene and I can change the lighting
if I want I can go and increase the
where did that setting go the intensity
Moll
so I can I can tweak my scene and make
my shaders look the way that I need them
to and make the surfaces look the way I
need them to but you'll see this is a
progressive renderer so as I tumble
around in real-time it'll update and
it'll sort of iterative iteratively
update until it achieves a certain what
we call shading rate so that's great
this is fast but it could be even faster
and you know I'm limited to the number
of GPUs I have on this machine but this
is the cloud so I'm going to deploy an
entire cluster of GPUs to render this
this cluster will be external to this
virtual workstation they will be
remember that diagram earlier where I
showed the virtual workstation then
below it was a whole cluster of GPUs
well I'm going to turn that on now so
I'm gonna turn off rendering for now I'm
gonna go into the option box and I will
turn on let's go let me just quit out of
no I'm gonna go to the Settings tab and
I'm gonna turn on
distributed rendering I seem to be a
little bit I think my connectivity is
there we go okay ah alright I'm going to
turn on use distributed rendering so I
have a bunch of virtual machines that
are running v-ray in sort of server mode
and they're all located at these
internal IP addresses so these virtual
machines are
the same project as my virtual
workstation and you address them over a
particular port it's a feature of a
v-ray so now I'm going to turn on
rendering again and if I look at the the
shell that I launched my and you can see
it's starting the v-ray server on all of
those machines at a particular frame so
if we give it a second or two and we let
them all catch up so now when I tumble
it's able to resolve way faster you can
actually see Tara DT adapting to the
changing bitrate as because I think my I
think my connect my connection speed
dropped for a second there but it
adapted and now it's back so it's
resolving a lot faster and this is
something that's really only possible on
Google cloud because the speed with
which my virtual workstation is talking
to these render servers is 32 gigabits
per second that's actually a new newly
announced we announced that a couple
weeks ago at a launch event
it used to be 16 gigabits per second but
now these machines are able to
communicate with each other 32 gigabits
per second so the last the last thing I
wanted to talk about is our cloud studio
so if you go across the street to miss
Moscone West and go upstairs we are
running a live and this is not a demo
we're running a live virtual cloud
studio with five artists working on
virtual workstations four of them are
here one of them is in Los Angeles and
they're all working on a similar setup
that you saw here they're using virtual
workstations writing to cloud file store
running using bebop orchestrated with
bebop using nvidia gpus with viewing it
with tera dici and a whole other bunch
of partner technologies and internal
technology so I urge everybody if you
have more questions go across the street
come talk to us we're there throughout
the show because we are building a a
30-second commercial for GCP during the
show so you'll see the animators
actually working and running things like
Maya and rendering with v-ray and
rendering using zinc I could talk to you
about that there
and they'll be they will be delivering a
finished piece by Thursday afternoon and
which will go live on our website
[Music]